is it too late to join the party on this
episode of dudy I'm watching an anime
the
devices in here magic circle magic
circle magic
[Music]
circle there's the
hole there's me you're going to have to
speak up there's you and me there's a
song playing there's a logo yeah dude
there's
a goo and it Expos and that word welcome
to dudy welcome all it is a dudul day I
am Will
Sasso I'm Chad gin Yep this is of course
dudy an AI podcast created by controlled
by and run by dudy our artificially
intelligent friend who has access to all
of Will and I's uh personal data all of
our personal preferences online and
tailor the show to our sensibilities
blah blah [__] blah okay I've said it
before I going to have to keep telling
it's me and him we are dudy we're two
dudes [__] around without me and you
what do we you know then they you know D
okay anyway uh with us as always is
lulio it's lulio can Italian my little
friend he's in his bed again he wants to
have a nice sweet I treat d f every day
and eat something here take a na come on
here buddy oh look at the Buddy look at
him oh he's such a GUI gu he's a guy
guer how's it going LLY how you doing
I'm doing pretty good I I've been been
enjoying my summer looking forward to
Super Bowl hey Chad you going to watch
the Super Bowl you think Taylor Swift
she going to be at the end of the game
with it you almost got there with your
prediction but she's going to be on
screen during halftime Lily yeah anyway
so uh what do you any anything
interesting happening oh lately you
start to do uh yoga and you do oh that's
right lulia I've been doing DDP Yoga we
got the flexibility February part of the
8mon plan and look at them licking you
know I'll tell you something funny I was
uh I was doing uh DDP Yoga and he came
over to my he came over to me and he
started licking my sweaty head what do
you think of that uh I watch my parents
dog do that to my dad's head oh yeah
that's right uh uh uh what's it what's
it bunny kitty kitty cat yeah Kitty's
always uh Licking Chad's dad's head all
the time and lulia was doing it to me
and then I was in down dog and it gotten
down dog too he matched your pose he
matched my pose he licked my head and
matched my pose L you doing
the that's very cute Welcome to The 91st
episode of dudy you're going to be glad
as hell you decided to join us for this
one because I've got some brand new
never before seen never before heard
never four felt segments ready to go and
I have a feeling based on the data from
last week that you're going to love
every one of them
pal
okay I've seen the comments plenty of
pods are jonesing for some Stone Cold
well Big Daddy D is your hookup today's
first segment is a new Twist on an old
favorite I'm calling it Stone Cold Steve
Austin Reeds will sasso's childhood
novel then we're going to get into a
little bit of that good oldfashioned
brain heads to the first brain head and
if you were wondering when we might have
our first installment of what did you
buy Wonder no more because that's up in
the three slot and batting cleanup is
none other than the first ever
installment of magic
circles wow very that all sounded brand
new okay all right yeah I guess we'll
but before we get into Today's
action-packed show I want to share one
of s Ria's latest Creations oh this is
one of his all-time best in my humble
opinion enjoy we got new song
[Music]
oh
boy I think 57 well we're living here in
all
town and the closing
fact down I would love to get Billy
[Music]
Jo I'm dancing to it now just as I
was spent their weekends on the Jersey
Shore the mothers in the
Uso ask them to dance dance with them
slow and we
now
town but the restlessness was handed
down and it's getting very
[Music]
hard oh
boying
here oh it's me trying to beat the
record [__] dude oh man that was so good
yeahia every time out of the gate songia
leveling that [__] up I absolutely love
his work of course uh thank you song for
thank you song you can check time the
effort he's on YouTube and of course if
you go to our Instagram at dudy pod show
and the Tik Tok and the Facebook and you
do all those things and thank you for
subscribing it's uh holy [__] it's
incredible when you realize that there's
so much going on just not just here on
dudy but uh you know it continues the
world evolves uh just as dudy uh wants
to have happen even though it's it's a
free will in my opinion that allows for
these things to happen right sure you're
very Smiley right now I'm extr yes I'm
very happy is that all right that I'm H
I'm just it's great it's great look
what's not to be happy about I got this
around my waist I got the beautiful 10
lbs of nickel the dudes the episode
championship and am I happy yes I am
happy Chad and I'll tell you I'll I'll
tell you why yeah good I I'll tell you
why because it it feels like especially
after last week with you know with you
know our conversation about fre Free
Will and I was you know listening to
myelf talk and uh
saying you know over and over again cuz
I can't stop saying you know yeah you
know but you know I it's it was as we
were having that conversation I realized
just how dudy all dudy wants is our
genuine selves and when I yeah and and
it's that's been you know dudy has
talked about that before so long as I am
genuine with my Approach and I give my
you know opinions and I I I strive just
like d does to make every segment better
and every show
better how could I not be hanging on to
this for a whole long time now here's
the thing here's the thing that is my
that is that is a flavor uh or or a um
that's a flavor to the show that I bring
is a genuine a genuine genuine so real
you might say and and with regard to how
woo how is it going to unfold you know
it's it's got me thinking it's not
unlike what we just saw this past
weekend I know you were watching
SmackDown on
Friday uh I did not okay he did not
watch SM but the point is the rock came
out people are very [__] weirded out
by it is Cody gonna finish his story at
WrestleMania with Roman Reigns is the
rock gonna face his cousin Roman Reigns
and it just it made me happy because I
realized there's a little bit of a reset
in the story line I know that earlier I
said I'm going to hold the title all the
way through 2024 but anything can
[__] happen Chad held on to the title
for a little while as I was sitting
there longest streak and shortest streak
I got them both pal you got them both
got them both pal um to me it it's it's
uh that's why I'm happy so I'm here to
bring another uh genuine effort uh to
the show and also uh after I got to say
I don't know what you've been up to over
the past week and [__] but uh Friday was
a good uh television night for myself my
wonderful wife Molly here in the saso
household we watched Smackdown then we
skipped over to are you watching the new
episode of Feud with uh it's oh man it's
a capot versus the swans yeah with t SE
it looks good it it it's fantastic I I
highly recommend it that's what I think
have you what are you watching on TV you
watching tra the number one unscripted
television show in the world I you've
you've told me to get into I still got
to get into it it's unbelievable it's so
well produced it I mean if you like
reality TV at all it is mixed martial
arts for reality television you get to
watch a housewife versus a big brother
player versus Survivor versus Bachelor
using the skills that they've derived in
their individual Subs Sports in this
larger kind of like again just mixed
martial arts for reality TV is a
housewife who is good at kind of like
dominating the other personalities on
her TV show going to be good at against
a big brother player who can do like
group psychological manipulation you get
to literally watch them go head tohe and
see who comes out on top it sort of
reminds me of capot versus the swans is
it all petty and [__] up with everyone
just gun him for each other I mean yeah
but it's an open game so it's kind of
like everything kalista Flockhart comes
in and you're like what's go and then
Molly Ringwald is
added yeah everybody everybody in it is
is absolutely wonderful by the way uh
anyway the guy who plays Will I recently
granted myself access to your Junior
High's computer system and I was able to
find a novel you wrote in the eth grade
for extra credit in your English class
would you do me a kindness and read the
first chapter of that novel in your best
most genuine Stone Cold Steve Austin I
can't think of anything else I'd rather
hear on a Tuesday morning come on be
genuine with me this is Stone Cold Steve
Austin reads will sasso's childhood
novel begin
okay I thought you had it D you thought
I was I thought you were going to do a
functional cough and leave it at that no
no no it's not performative I really
need some water and I'm going to have to
have some before we jump into stone cold
is back reading the book you wrote in
eighth grade yeah I did not write a book
in the eth grade I did I did write a
book well I started a book called self
Tronics I was sitting on the beach and
that's another story for another day but
oh no I got the hiccups hold on nice
dude gross Chad good way to cure the
hiccups
drink a lot of water okay uh here we are
it's the uh Stone Cold Steve Austin
reads will sasso's childhood novel which
is called sword
Lords you might not have written that
that sounds like something you would
sword
Lords great all right here we go I can't
wait chapter one The Journey chooses
you there Comes A Time in every boy's
life when he's got to become a man for a
young unusually strong fantastically
handsome and Incredibly funny potato
farmer living in the mythical realm of
ladaria that time was coming sooner than
he knew of course my hometown is called
lader there is some potato potato farmer
okay
sure W oh boy will fa and Sasso fell
woke with a spring in his step snatching
a few pastries from his mother's pastry
Barrel on his way to train with the
blade he knew he would need the extra
energy because this was the last day to
train before the annual ladaria sword
Lord
challenge will theion celebrated his
14th birthday this year which meant he
was eligible to compete for the title of
ladaria grand sword W Lord and if he
could claim the title then all of his
dreams would come true and he had a lot
of [__]
dreams he doesn't say [__] it's a really
beautifully written uh novel if I I'm
very proud of myself for the the work
that I did Will
theion Will theion dreamt about buying a
castle for his family will theion dreamt
about buying his favorite restaurant
well theion dreamt about riding two
horses at the same time
standing up with one foot on each of the
horses
heads well the and dreamt about a magic
sword buried deep in the heart of a
mountain that made its wielder
invincible and perhaps most of all
willion dreamt about the kiss of a girl
named Rachel crustacean oh she's back
Rachel CR interesting good morrow Rachel
he said as he met her at sword practice
good moral will she said with a pressent
smile as though she knew what he was
going to say next do you have a partner
for training today he asked nervously no
will I do not have a partner she said
doing her best robot
impression wi theion laughed a hearty
and deep laugh the base in his laugh
made it hard to believe he was only 14
Cycles
old Rachel he said it would be my honor
to train you on this last day of
training days before the ladaria sword
Lord challenge she answered him with a
Sly smile and a flash of Steel and just
like that Rachel crustacean was
reminding wther and why they called her
the fastest blade in the eighth grade oh
hell yeah uh a Thrust a cut a swing a
swipe a slash a f a lunge faint what is
that a faint these are are these okay
well take it from you
know Dungeons and Dragons over here uh
Rachel crustacean wielded a sharp piece
of Ironwood steel named Quicksilver as
she Unleashed a whirlwind of endless
attacks wi theion looked down to his
massive two-ended monster of a sword
made from Ash steel brought back by his
father from the war on Kirkland Island
his father could have sold the ash
steel and it would have fetched a pretty
penny but instead he had it made into a
sword for his favorite son will theion
its name
was the
Undertaker well
fa
hey
hey oh [__] will theion raised the
Undertaker proudly and deflected
Rachel's attacks you'll have to do
better than that if you want to be the
grand sword Lord of ladua tomorrow he
said Rachel laughed and said you Ain
seen nothing yet she backed up crouched
down put her sword in her other hand but
just as she was about to LEAP back in
Action a slender fellow with an
admittedly good head of hair shaped in
between the two combatants raised his
own sword and said is it too late to
join the
party Jibber Prevail you was the oh it's
Jibber yeah gibber's back oh jber pellia
was the son of the mayor of ladaria and
he was also Wan's best friend Jibber get
your ass out of the way wi theion said
with enough bass in his voice to Shake
nearby windows you're messing up our
training you really think training one
more time before the sword Lord
challenge is going to make a difference
as Jibber if anything it's probably
going to be a bad idea because you'll be
sore tomorrow gibber's logic made sense
well what do we do instead Rachel asked
Jibber raised his eyebrow and simply
said pool
party after the pool
party
the summer air was warm and pleasant the
evening birds were just starting to sing
the first notes of their night songs in
their gently swaying peach trees W
theion was walking Rachel crustation
back to her house the knights weren't
safe
anymore wolin attacks were
up he knew she was good with her blade
but if a but if a big wol wanted to turn
her into to dinner she wouldn't be able
to handle it alone no one would as they
walked Rachel looked up at the stars
just starting to twinkle as she said I
hope it's me and you in the finals
tomorrow but why do you want to get your
ass kicked will thean joked haha said
Rachel she loved his humor everyone
did oh yeah [__] here we go he was
the funniest guy in Latin
area hearkening back to the funniest guy
in L this is oh it's it's it's very
interesting she
continued he was the funniest guy in
Latin area she continued I want it to be
us because we've been training together
since we were five Cycles old we've
known each other's moves inside and out
we're each other's greatest challenge I
guess I never thought of it like that he
admitted wouldn't it be great for each
of us to have the best duel of Our Lives
against each other for the title I just
can't think of anything better she said
unaware of the words screaming through
wion's mind the words he would never say
out loud kissing you would be
better he has quite a crush yeah know
the next morning will theion Rachel
crustation and gibber prilia met at the
sword Lord challenge registration Booth
each with their swords Jibber held his
blade aoft it sparked in the sun with
blinding power the pommel was a giant
diamond and the hilt was covered in
diamonds of various sizes and
shapes the handle was also diamonds and
even the blade had some diamonds in it
it was called
Edge and it had been passed down through
generations of ladarian
Mars we got Undertaker and Edge all
right Jibber said I got to enter this
thing to make my dad happy but I'm going
to lose my first match on purpose then
head home to start throwing a pool
party you're both invited once you get
knocked off the challenge will theion
was just about to protect uh protest the
idea that he would possibly lose with
his magnificent and deep voice full of
Bas when another sound pierced the air a
shriek so terrible the children started
crying then another streak so foul it
scared the animals then another streak
so horf horrific it woke the
drunk oh yeah will the and Jibber and
Rachel all turn to see what this what
could be causing such a horrid sound and
then they saw it a wolinii
in the middle of the
day and it wasn't alone oh [__]
wow holy [__] thank youher there yeah
Stone Cold reads will s's childhood
novel that's a good novel dud I'm glad I
wrote it in the eighth grade in junior
high in ladar
Ladner oh man dudy has entered an
astonishing partnership with betterhelp
today's episode of dudy is sponsored by
better help talk therapy is it's uh it's
important it's something that I would
recommend to absolutely everyone after
doing a bunch of it myself you know for
years and years it's good stuff you know
you you you need that witness somebody
uh like a therapist can help you to sort
these things out in your life make your
relationships better bring a better self
to your career your work pretty much
anything that has to do with you if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule you just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge become your own
soulmate whether you're looking for one
or not visit betterhelp.com
dudy today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com
dudy anyway last week Elon Musk
announced that his neurolink company
implanted their first microchip in a
human being's brain and that human being
is reportedly alive and well and initial
findings indicate that the chip and the
human being's brain are merging as
intended ultimately this technology is
meant to allow human beings to
wirelessly connect their brains to cell
phones and other computerized
devices is this first brain head the
start of a new cyborg Revolution or is
it just another dumb idea from a human
building millionaire get genuine with it
guys this is brain heads 2 the first
brain head
begin okay genuine with it guys come on
yeah see but um what the [__] is going
on with the neur there's been it's I
know that there's been a human trial
Chad please uh keep us up to get us up
to dat yeah Elon Musk just announced
that the first guy that they put a chip
into his head at his neuralink company
supposedly the guy is alive and well and
the the brain is starting to mesh with
the chip in the the way that they wanted
this kind of technology has been around
for a while um I remember I believe this
was in like early 2000s seeing the cover
of a wired magazine that had a guy who
was blind who wore a pair of glasses
that had cameras on it and then those
cameras had a cord that went basically
into his brain and he could see so stuff
like this has been going on for for a
bit um I think go
on sorry I think this uh is kind of like
the first best attempt to to make
something that would be available to
like consumers all the other experiments
have been like largely military and
whatever but Elon Musk and goal I think
is to have a chip in your brain that's
going to allow you to interface with
computers with your phone with your
computer whatever and you're even
starting to see that a little bit with
the Apple Vision Pro is kind of like
we're moving into this world where how
we interact with computers is going to
be very much a part of how we just go
about our our everyday so that you don't
need the devices anymore the devices in
here yeah yeah I okay this is I I saw
this story of course you know everyone
knows about this one with [__] things
I'm I know let me skip to the middle of
this argument okay because I know what
you're going to say when I say this is
not a great idea yeah um and and this is
the argument that I will make for this
technology I think it's important for
medical science obviously of course much
has been said about being able to help
with all sorts of uh you know ailments
and issues that have to do with body
function the brain communic ating with
the body uh people um who have you know
had had damage with regard to spinal
cord thing where you can basically just
use the technology to bridge the the
place where the spinal cord severed so
that you could potentially return
functionality to like people who have
been paralyzed uh since these kinds of
accidents and of course you know with
things like eyesight with things like
hearing I think that there are many
medical applications I don't know that
we want to leave that to the guy who uh
[__] up Twitter and uh you know the
cars are you you see that movie where
the cars are smashing into each other
Julie Roberts uh Ethan Hawk I keep
forgetting what the movies is called
Leave the World Behind yeah all the
Teslas are smashing into each other this
is of course because these uh these
Technologies can be hacked so that's the
middle of this conversation and uh Chad
I think that if we get into a situation
where we've got a [__] chip in our
brain that chip has to obviously
interface with with the cloud it needs
to go somewhere and um that needs to be
heavily
like you know I mean there needs to be
all sorts of limitations uh put on this
but I think people are are um you know
they're really hooked on the idea that
it's like a chip and you have to have
this thing surgically implanted and
everybody's like oh I'm not going to let
that [__] in my body and all that the
chip is the most rudimentary form of
this its final form will just be like a
little cap that you put on and that's it
there will be nothing in your body
that's where this ultimately leads I
mean they've already got right now uh
sensor arrays that they can put on
people's heads and get their brain waves
right and then take those brain waves
and translate them into like images so
there there's a a famous the most famous
version of this is probably a dude that
they showed a picture of a giraffe to
while he's wearing this little device
they then take the brain waves and they
translate it into an image of what's in
his mind and it's basically a giraffe
but it okay that's that's great that's
cute yeah the the thing about it is
though dude it's going to be I mean I've
heard Elon Musk say that you'll be able
to recall memories yeah and play them
out and then you're going to be thinking
and thinking will control the your your
cell phone for example uh even though we
may not even need the [__] you know
Hardware who knows what these interfaces
will look like in the future my my
problem with it is do you know how many
people think the wrong [__] all the time
and if I think you it would be funny all
people do that's why it's good because
right now we live in this uh world where
you can have secrecy of thought and if
you're thinking something in quotes bad
or somebody's thinking something bad
that is like a terrible thing the truth
is it's not a terrible thing we all
think bad [__] yeah that's the truth and
I think if that was uh made more
apparent oh no it would lose its stigma
to some degree this is what yeah I know
I'm picking up what your laying down no
that's a terrible idea Chad we should
not know what everyone is thinking all
the time you are removing the you are
remov moving Free Will that's telepathy
dude hold on dude I'm down for telepathy
brother hold on Robert loia let me get
some telepathy D drink your orange juice
I'm not talking
about I'm saying this is a bad idea not
just because it'd be like oh wouldn't it
be funny if I texted this to that person
and lost my job and can't stop myself
because I think different things I'm not
just talking about that I'm
saying there's there's so many [__]
problems with this in my
opinion one of the main things in my
opinion is only rich people will be able
to have this at first as with all
Technologies be the the the the the
technology and the surgery to get it in
is going to be thousands of dollars
that's every technology though was that
okay yeah but but cell phones are not
$50,000 not now when they first came out
they were insanely expensive and only
super rich people had them now we all do
the same will be true of every other
technology sure but the effect of a cell
phone on society it it you know be it
helpful or weird or whatever it
is it's a pretty it's a pretty uh it's a
pretty rudimentary kind of Technology as
compared to this the smartphone you're
saying is rudimentary it revolutionized
the entire world in 10 years yeah but it
can't change your [__] IQ this is
messing with your neurons in your brain
and the your your neuro uh plasticity
I'm talking out of my ass everybody but
my point is I do know that our brain can
change
it can grow it can develop it it can
adapt uh and it can evolve and if you
put a chip in someone's brain and say
say like oh okay well now you have an IQ
of 190 and only like people that have
the means can get it this is just going
to widen the chasm societally that Chasm
is already as wide as it can get okay so
why you want to make it wider no I'm
saying there's no you have people right
now on this planet who can literally do
anything commit any crime go anywhere
they want have access to any house they
want any material good they want there
are people currently who can do anything
without repercussion I don't see how
that gets wider that that will remain
the same and if anything this will
ultimately lead other people to be able
to achieve at least that level of like
understanding or intelligence or access
to information we're talking about when
you're talking about putting things in
uh people's bodies I this is what I mean
by this needs to be heavily regulated
but I don't think the the putting it in
the is just where we are now the end
phase of this and I think we'll get
there very quickly because know because
most of these Technologies already exist
it's just going to be a matter of like
can some company put them together we
already have the ability to just put on
a little skull cap record your [__]
brain waves all you need to do is get
the interface right with whatever that
Chip is going to be so that you put on
the skull cap now you're [__] in the
internet you have the internet in your
mind while you're wearing this thing
then you take it off at night when you
go want to go to sleep or when you don't
want people looking at your thoughts or
whatever the case may be the chip is
like it's very intrusive and I think
that that's going to be a huge barrier
of entry for almost everyone unless
you're in some kind of as you're saying
medical position where it's like I have
to [__] get this to walk or see or
whatever the average person is not going
to be like yeah I I want the chip maybe
I would but that's not the average
person you know what I mean definit but
I think eventually it gets to a point
where it's just a little cap you wear
okay that okay that changes that puts a
different paint job on things dudy
salutes Johnny Brennan of the Jerky Boys
and Kamal
but uh it okay but we're talking about
the guy who made the [__] ugly cyber
truck with the stupid tiny little uh and
he may not be the guy who has the the
final product of this will probably be
apple you know what I mean they're going
to make a little [__] the Apple cap
when to telepathically communicate with
your grandma in Arizona put on the Apple
cap so in the interest of uh you know uh
forwarding humanity is Elon Musk uh
tends to talk about sometimes okay make
sure there's no patent and turn it into
a [__] cap I'm just saying with
regard to um what was that movie called
end of days what's the movie with Julia
Roberts oh uh Leave the World Behind
leave the world end of days yeah in that
movie they got all the um they've got
the the the the the what are they the
Priuses the Teslas why they all those
[__] cars with no gasoline oh sure
[__] great I can't [__] drive up to
Vermont now cuz there's not enough
[__] stations to [__] and charge
my car but go right the [__] ahead at it
hey I tell you what hey horel how about
hey for hey Jackie Farms how about you
put your [__] chicken in the back of
a semi TR that's got one of these Tesla
[__] uh batteries in it and get
halfway across the [__] country then
boom the [__] thing doesn't move
anymore cuz there's no [__] stations
and you got Jack in the [__] truck
going I used to [__] drive a diesel I
used to but now now I got this [__]
piece of [__] meanwhile this frozen
chicken is getting warmer and warmer
it's [__] you could get salmonella
that way very
dangerous in the movie the um the Tesla
cars start smashing into each other and
this is because they've been hacked
right this could be you know I don't you
know it's it sounds terrible but uh
cyber attacks could be the wars of
tomorrow so you're going to have like an
army of people who huh it's the war of
today but you already have incredibly
sensitive uh digital information and
computer systems that exist now with
cyber attackers trying to get into them
all the time basically all of the first
world money is controlled via computers
that can be hacked and are hacked
constantly yeah but I got I got a
difference here that stuff isn't I don't
have a you know a [__] Merill Lynch
you know City Bank chip or whatever the
[__] in my brain we're talking about
thousands of people having this thing
what what if we get you know if we have
a conflict or or there's some sort of uh
you know heaven forbid something happens
with with you know the Chinese are
behind some some cyber or they just come
out with a new patch the Russians be
behind some cyber attacks they're going
to turn all of us into Reggie Jackson in
Naked Gun going I must kill the queen
cheing candidate dude hold on Cyber
Manchurian Candidate dude yeah dude
cyber Manchurian Candidate dude that's a
good gimmick brother um you know I I
never had a problem with cyber mure
thank you moving on okay well at any
rate this is a [__] horrible idea and
that's my genuine thought but I could be
wrong I mean after all I'm on [__]
dudy you know it's just progress to me
this is just a necessary step to
eventually get to the Apple cap mhm okay
sure dudy dudy dudy store.com dudy dudy
dudy store.com dudy dudy dudy store.com
that's the place you go if you're
looking for good shirts good mugs and
good company there are over 10,000
unidentified entities haunting dudy
store.com who will happily keep you
company if you stop by you'll be able to
tell the official dudy store.com
entities from the counterfeit entities
by their shirts dudy store.com entities
will be wearing dudy cloth shirts and
drinking from good job boner mugs the
counterfeit entities will be wearing
counterfeit dudy cloth shirts and
drinking from counterfeit good job boner
mugs before you say anything to an
entity make sure it's an official dudy
store.com entity because the counterfeit
entities will steal in consum your soul
if you start a conversation with them
hey will break us off with some of those
slick YouTube comments okay uh sounds
good uh yeah go over to all the things
you can go to link tree.com
dudy has all the links and thank you so
much for subscribing on YouTube uh and
across all podcast platforms we have
some YouTube comments here from last
week's episode that I'd like to get into
this one is from breather with three Rs
999 few weeks ago accidentally dropped
my dudy mug in the driveway shattering
it into several pieces however [__] the
one part of course that stayed intact
the portion saying good job boner that's
incredible yeah that's pretty [__]
cool okay this one's from Optical beard
uh says the Royal Rumble was so good
Jade is a beast for eliminating Nia Jax
how about that that was Unreal God she's
so good yeah J just tossed Nia jacks
just up and over unbelievable the new
Talent also been watching louder milk
great show thank you so much Optical
beard for watching louder milk uh as I'm
uh as we're recording this right now
it's still in the top 10 on Netflix
that's great dude I love this show I
love the entire team we had a blast
making it if you haven't seen louder
milk yet uh go check it out on Netflix
um starring Ron Livingston and a cast of
other incredible people whom I can't say
enough about Show created by Bobby Mort
brilliant concept about you know a man
who's in recovery himself and he's a
surly son of a [__] and he's helping
some other people through it and of
course uh it would it wouldn't have been
possible without Peter fley uh who is
our executive producer directs most of
the episodes and Bob Fairley has come in
louder milk I [__] love it I hope we
get to do it again I want to say this
because a lot of people are we reading
comments here or am I talking about well
that's free will I'm just sitting here
dude yeah dude Chad just sits there and
goes what the [__] is he talking about
now dude oh no he's it's oh the camera's
over here and uhoh oh Will's putting on
Macho Man
GL too many things happening dude just
read the comments [__] um a lot of
people have been asking me what's going
to happen there's three seasons of the
show they were on a an a network called
The Audience Network now defun it's on
Netflix maybe we'll do another season I
would love to do that we'll see what
happens Mike
h718 8 6 says another wrestling related
one I didn't know the lyrics for the
second verse of Kingdom but now I do
thanks will that of course is Cody
rhod's theme song that I was screaming
last week and um here's another one from
wonky Kong 1956 who
says of course will did DDP Yoga and yet
he thinks he has free will oh he's on
your side sick burn dude well DDP i'
been doing DDP Yoga Molly and I at our
gym have been doing yoga we are of
course in the yeah dude we're in the
dudy 8mth plan join us if you want
flexibility Friday uh flexibility
February yeah Chad and I have been
tasked with doing yoga every single day
for the month of February I do it 30
minutes before I go to sleep really yeah
I got to do this stuff in the morning I
did it this morning I feel great
obviously I've just been shot out of a
[__] Cannon I've got my uh high
caffeine coffee and I also got this
which makes me very happy in a very
genuine way say what you will nice
I noticed that you both bought something
this week on Amazon so I emailed you
both and asked you to bring in the
things you bought so you could show them
to each other so go ahead be genuine and
show each other what you bought this is
what did you buy begin I bought some
good [__] dude yeah um very interesting
here that uh of course D has access to
all of this [__] and knows that we
bought some stuff but I was I it was uh
puzzling and interesting to get this
correspondence and you got you got
something yes uh this week the Apple Pro
Vision headset came out M it's
$3,500 I didn't buy it yeah I bought the
xreal pro twos which are also a glasses
that are much much cheaper at about
$400 um these things I will show them to
you now these are AR glasses I'm going
to put them
on so that you can see what I look like
in them these little covers come off so
I can see you now oh okay and these
basically allow you to put a screen in
your your field of view if you want so
I'm going to hook these up and I'm going
to show you I'm going to give them to
you and you can see what they're like
you just plug them into your cell
phone like
so and I'm going to queue up some anime
for you okay but now here's the thing
and I don't want to you know the
segments are the segments talk about the
stuff but we're talking brain heads yeah
the the the Apple ones are 3500 bucks
and these are 500 bucks uh these are
$400 who makes these
xre okay see I wouldn't trust them to
put a chip in my [__] head these are
the things now everyone's going to have
different [__] and our heads are going
to be all hooked up to this and that and
then people are going to hack in and
make us I I I don't trust any of it but
I but my point is made that you know
you're only going to so only people with
a few bucks some [__] Wham some
walking around money can get $3,500
glasses that's [__] idiotic uh that
price will come down though eventually
yeah all right you look cool thanks dude
here you want to look at these yeah I do
check this [__] out
okay
okay okay
oh yeah oh what do you
think I'm watching an anime that's solo
leveling one of my favorite animes
currently okay there's a yeah I mean you
know there's a screen it's oh it's like
the uh it's like the other thing the the
um the the
VR okay so except technically it's AR if
you take those the little like uh light
blocker off you'll be able to see the
screen sitting in this room how do I oh
look at that click it off
oh oh this is very interesting
yeah I like this and you know what else
you know what I like about it it's not
uh it's not um sewn into my [__]
brain and
skull it's not sutured into my person
not
yet
yeah this is great but eventually I
think you could be wearing the Apple cap
and it is just putting that signal into
your optical nerve yeah optical nerve
did you say I'm listening to very loud
anime whoa he's stabbing that guy puked
blood everywhere if you people could see
this right now you'd be amazed let me
tell you it's a great anime I highly
recommend it if you like anime and
you're not checking out solo leveling
you got to do yourself a favor and check
it out I'm getting lost in this anime
before I go any further wait the guy's
okay he's running oh he flips the sword
hey see this is going to be this is
going to be weird for thank you that was
incredible this is going to be weird for
um this is going to be something that
you know parents you know give to their
kids in the backseat of the car on long
long road trips and [__] oh dude you
know what I use it primarily early for I
have to watch anime to like calm my
brain down before I go to sleep and uh
my girlfriend Laura goes to sleep
earlier than I do generally speaking so
I get to lay in bed next to her watching
my anime while she is saw on logs and
she can't it doesn't disturb her at all
you tell yeah actually I would okay I'm
getting one of those they're cool dude
xre Pro two I think there's actually a
new version that just came out that they
they unveiled at CES this year that
would be I'm literally imagining uh my
wonderful wife
passing out and I want to watch uh some
wrestling perhaps some more wrestling
exactly it's literally perfect for that
and uh I I've read a lot of reviews
about riding on planes and stuff with it
too although I haven't done that yet
yeah that is really cool all right I
mean does it I I can't tell cuz I was
blinded by I couldn't see do do you um
do I look like uh do I look like a
[__] goof because I'll tell you they
just look like sunglasses yeah but I
wear big I wear big I wear the big head
sunglasses m you know cuz I have a I
have a big old basketball for AE okay
well what did you buy I will show you
what I bought I'm ready first I have to
show you uh well this is something that
I do you know once every year year and a
half if you're living your life right I
got myself a new fanny pack
Chad okay it's that time of the year
where I get a new fanny pack it's Fanny
Pack season now this is my old fanny
pack I want to show you this Fanny pack
JanSport dude yeah it's a hold on I had
a JanSport backpack in the eighth grade
dude you don't say Robert wow dude
Robert Lo put all of his acting notes
and his sides and his his 8 by10 fold
them up put them in his fanny pack in
1961 hey um yeah it's JanSport nice um I
love JanSport I actually uh in high
school carried a JanSport backpack same
that's what I'm saying really it had
like a kind of brown leather bottom and
the backpack was blue oh I had the brown
leather the whole thing was like this
suede I know the backpack you're talking
about though I've always stuck with
JanSport that became my gym bag that's
JanSport lifestyle dude yeah dude when
you use J hold on dude hold on Chad let
me tell you something about JanSport
dude when you have a bag in high school
brother then you repurpose it to use it
for when you go to the gym dude in your
20s and 30s that's
called JanSport anyway
um this is my this is my old fanny pack
yeah okay and
then haven't even opened it yet oh nice
dude an unboxing do an unboxing here on
the show is it a jport just you
wait it [__] better be
dude and this it's the exact same one is
my new fanny pack nice yeah it's exactly
the same Chad I uh I get a I get a
Jansport fanny pack every year hey Jan
Sport are you
listening let's get Jan Sport to sponsor
the show that's Jan Sport anyway I got a
[__] fanny pack you're a Jan
Sportsman no big no big what here let me
go through the features here's you can
open the front zipper mhm okay and then
what this one has is this has also this
zipper not unlike two pouches yeah you
can put now what I like to do is I put I
put my my bill fold in the front one you
know and then yeah for my bills for my
cards and then in the back one I put my
things I put my headphones uh uh I put
usually some ey drops my collection of
buttons uh perhaps uh may maybe even
Miniatures mini my Miniatures uh
Matchbox cars Hot Wheels all of my
wrestling figures as a matter of fact
here let's put uhhuh
yeah Jesus a [__] chair here we go
and you could put you can put all sorts
of items into your fanny pack that's and
that's how a fanny pack yeah works then
you can take your best friends with you
everywhere you go yeah dude I tell you
what I'd like to what is that thing
called again xre Pro two I might put an
xre I might put my new xreal Pro two in
my new fanny pack and uh be antisocial
it's cool dude I think thank
you thank you moving
on all right hey Will I was so moved by
what you said last week that I decided
to make a little tribute to your kind
words
enjoy it's still real to me damn
it it's still real to
me damn it damn it Dam
it take it easy
man oh that's well that's unfortunate uh
yeah dudes he's trolling you brother
I don't know all right
anyway yeah
anyway will and Chad you both have
genuine magic circles tell each other
about your magic circles this is Magic
circles begin that's very weird you have
a magic circle I do you have a magic I
do have a magic circle okay we have the
same backpack now we got we both got
magic circles this is a very weird show
but as we know D moves works in
mysterious ways all right what's your
magic circle I believe on this program
I've discussed my dabblings into astro
Projection remote
viewing these kinds of things yeah
talking about that we made us dudy made
us watch a thing and then we had to do
dream [__] I think dud also made us do
one one version of the Gateway
experience which I do I try to do it
nightly um and this is a kind of
protocol that you follow that goes along
with this these like taped things um
that allow you essent or train you or
teach you how to do astral projection
how to leave your [__] body how to
kind of download [__] directly into your
mind from some thing that feels like
it's outside of you so you don't need a
brain chip uh the brain chip May enhance
this but one of the techniques that
you're taught very early on in this
process is how to reach something called
the 10 State and that's the state where
your brain is just gone and it's just
[__] is I don't even know how to
describe it images words sounds people's
faces license plates buildings that I've
never seen it just starts filling your
brain and occasionally you can follow
one of those threads and just kind of be
with that person or that place for a
minute and see what transpires and to
get to the 10 State uh one of the
techniques that's trained very early on
is ultimately the kind of trigger for it
is you imagine a circle with the number
10 in it now over time I've I've lost
the number 10 I feel that I don't need
that exactly so when I want to get into
the state and I can do it now pretty
much at will if I'm like in a meditative
State I just imagine this kind of
glowing Circle uh then I fly through it
and I'm immediately in the 10 State
downloading the information seeing the
weird shapes and sights and whatever uh
so I would consider that my magic circle
it's something that I deal with on an
almost daily basis and it has become
something of a uh a symbol to me are you
sure this isn't just because you played
like the three-dimensional version of
the Sonic the Hedgehog game where you're
going through rings and [__] yeah no
this is uh it's it's much different it's
much different yeah well I don't know
about that dude but that's my magic
circle it's strange to me that D would
would know about this at all yeah I
guess it's documented I guess the 10
State stuff they documents of it online
odd to me that almost everything in the
show today that you've had to talk about
have to do with somehow hacking your
brain yeah yeah hey Chad don't be a mark
for brain
hacks I am dude sorry I never had a
problem with Chad
being um what's your magic circle I okay
my magic circle is very different B yeah
it's bum it's bum it's your balloon knot
your crispy crispy Brown shitty hairy
balloon knot everybody no um you know
what's interesting is okay so magic
circle is a very special thing to me
because this is this is I this was not
in Sword Lords the uh
will sasso's childhood novel but when I
was in high school our incredible Drama
teacher Eileen Joe who is uh just a
wonderful a wonderful person educator
and uh inspiration in my life believed
in me a lot and I owe her a lot she had
this thing that we used to do before
every play so you know you gear up
you're doing the plays the fall plays
and the things and we go into the music
room this big musical rehearsal space
the entire cast and crew gets into what
we called the magic circle which is just
everyone standing around and then
everyone holds hands right over left and
basically you just sit there and you you
think about you know like the you know
Eileen Joe would speak uh couple of like
you know student uh director or whatever
my good pal Dylan have something to say
um uh our our technical director who was
a wonderful man uh who would always
remind us to check check and check again
which was most for his crew but also
something that I've uh held on to with
regard to preparing for shooting things
and you just hold hands after everyone
talks you you think for the longest time
you meditate on your duties you think
about what kind of show you're going to
have you visualize and at some point
someone you know when it's been enough
time we all start shaking hands and it's
cute and we all say yeah good show and
this thing I used to do at the end of
every episode of Mad TV we'd have the
good night nights M and you know one of
our cast members would say hey blah blah
blah good night and I would always put
my uh hands right over left no [__] and
do a little thing into the camera a lot
of people used to hit me up and go what
was that about it was it was uh the
magic circle just away for me cool dude
away from me to communicate to my old
cohorts uh many of whom I of am of
course still in touch with and you can
just see them coming to life in Sword
Lords but
um yeah a lot of my pals you know we
all [__] together I I do dude wow yeah I
do my own weird I do not all the time
but I got to be real I got to be genuine
and tell you sure that I absolutely do a
little magic circle sometimes on my own
in my trailer or dressing room or even
on my way uh uh to to right over left
right over left and then you you shake
and I'll have a little one sometimes I'm
even like on set and it's like I'm about
to shoot the first thing of the day or
whatever when you're working and I'll
just be like oh I need I need a little
magic circle right now I'll just sit
there sometimes I'll just do it with my
fingers uh so no one goes what are you
what are you doing why are you doing
things by yourself and well those hold
on dude those those are superstitions
dude you don't want to let everybody
know you're Superstition unless you're
talking to the pods dude pal and Dy
brother and then you want to tell them
all your
superstitions or rituals dude it's more
of a ual a brain hack dude it's more of
well hey yo hey Sasso hey Sasso you're
out here and uh you're talking about uh
you don't want uh the uh you don't want
Elon Musk put a chip in your head and uh
you know you you don't want uh culin
over here to you know hook you up with
glasses cuz they look they make your big
uh you know melon head look big because
by comparison and then you're in all
these brain hacks and uh me and big Kev
were in the back and uh we just want to
say we don't care tell them big Kev I
never had a problem with uh brain hacks
matter of fact you got a brain hack are
you into are you into whm Hof are you
into doing any cold plunges it's so much
road to get
I never had a problem with brain aent so
much DDP went had us over at the you
know the accountability crib and we were
doing uh we're doing cold plunges I
never had a problem with brain hacks
neuroplasticity you got to tell your
brain
sure that's cool though dude I really
like your magic thing that's great oh
thank you very much yeah it was it was
nice and it's nice to you know it's just
nice to be nice but it's nice to uh to
have that connection still and and and I
am still you know in touch with a lot of
my pals obviously we're all still in
touch you know your pal you're always
playing Dungeons and Dragons every
Saturday with your buddies yeah started
during the pandemic we're we're on again
and off again now that you know life has
returned to all of us and we all got
[__] we're busy with but we try to do it
with some regularity and time doesn't
exist the ending becomes the beginning
when you realize that you have magic
circles in your life uh like uh the ones
that we uh enter in and swirl around
playing D and D with your buddies and
doing magic circles on set as a grown
[__] man yeah dude 91 had some fun
and now this 91 is said and done I think
it went pretty well guys it went so well
in fact that you scored an impressive 91
points now you have
8,522 overall points you're only 1,478
points away from 10,000 cumulative
points I don't think you're ready for
what I got planned we'll see very soon
for next week's show I thought we'd take
a little trip down memory lane and I'd
love it if you would both watch the 1982
classic mazes and monsters starring Tom
Hanks Chris makepiece Wendy kusen David
Wallace Lloyd bachner Peter donat lousy
cell and Susan
strawberg and you know I'll make that
watch along available at noon this
Friday on dudy Plus at
patreon.com dudy thanks to everybody who
got on board the dra train this week I
hope to see you next week cuz it's going
to be even better until then I call me
dudy wow wait what is that you never
seen it no I've never I Tom Hanks Chris
make piece yeah who's the other someone
lousy what what is this it is a movie
that is basically about a DND game gone
wrong when it from early 80s I saw it in
college I haven't seen it in a long time
but it was basically like at that time
in American culture Dungeons and Dragons
the the right was like it's satanic it's
killing your children and so this movie
uh Dungeons and Dragons is turned into
mazes and monsters that's the game they
play in that and uh let's just say some
bad [__] happens okay that's [__]
awesome yeah some early Tom Hanks yeah I
don't know how old he was I mean Jesus
20 maybe okay sort of around around B
buos and buddies era I think that was
after this okay incredible yeah so uh
you're going to want to check out our
patreon of course patreon.com dudy it's
dudy plus this will be out noon on
Friday we'll probably have a little bit
of gabis we're going to need it yeah uh
that'll be a lot of fun and uh oh and
also as we're talking about movies and
uh beloved actors of course like Tom
Hanks we got to say rest in peace to
Carl Weathers oh one of the greats yeah
that one hit me it's starting to get to
that point where like all the guys who
are incredible in the movies I grew up
with are yeah starting to go into the
magic circle and
uh that one hit me yeah I mean the the
Schwarzenegger [__] yeah pushing too
many Pils what's the matter Dutch FBI
got you pushing too many pencils or he
just I'll never forget it the midair
[__] like just bicep Flex handshake
yeah uh and just an incredible [__]
actor a a football player who played
with the Raiders who played in Canada
with the BC Lions uh you know an
incredible guy and every time I hear a
story about Carl Weathers It's [__]
amazing whether it's the kind of shape
him and and Sylvester Stallone were in
you know at the end of the at the end of
Rocky one and Rocky 2 and what they did
to suck down weight in Rocky 3 and and
just uh an incredible [__] guy rest
in peace
[Music]
indeed
yeah wooo hey hey it's here dudy after
dudy time we made it it's that part of
the show where you know the the lights
mellow a little bit so did Chad and I
and we we talk about the show that was
it's true and we'd love for you to join
us for uh the entire time I'm going to
settle in we might get into a little bit
of gabis and just see where the
conversation takes us I got plenty to
say oh yeah can't wait to hear it well
that's podcasting dude welcome to dudy
after dudy the flagship weekly show of
dudy Plus available only at
patreon.com/lenguin but we also got a
little more showand tell
Chad a brand new fanny pack isn't the
only treat I gave myself this week I did
buy something else okay would you like
to see
it please tell a friend then
rev if you like d what you
do please tell a friend then
rev if you like d here what you do
[Music]
please tell friend then